- Do you think that, I know
it's hard when you have kids
and there's a divorce, do you
think that your son actually
helped you a bit though?
'Cause at least having that
little light in your life,
like do you know what I'm saying?
When it's so dark and it's
so do you think your son
kinda helped you get through--
- Well, parenting is a
very, you can, it's a,
you have to be selfless.
- Ah I know.
- So it helped me in a sense.
- Exhausting.
- Right, aren't they so demanding?
- And they still aren't thankful.
- I know.
But what helps about that
is that you're just not
always so self focused, you know.
- You're ego's in check, yeah.
- No, you're like no,
I'm a mom and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do my best,
I'm committed to this
and that is a very healthy,
I don't wanna say distraction
but, preoccupation
that you love and enjoy
and it does bring pleasure
in your life in that sense of course.
So it just wasn't always
about me all the time
and that was very very
helpful and you have to live
to tell the story, you
know I don't even remember
who this quote was from, but
you know you've gotta live it
to survive to tell the story
so the hunter doesn't get the glory.
- Wow.
- And whatever it is that
I, has pounced on you
or is challenging you
or weighing you down,
you can't let it win.
You have to survive and
then it's so important
to tell the story, to share the story.
So you've gotta survive to tell the story
and I just believe that that's
a great motto when you're--
- I love that, I want it like on a shirt--
- Really like you want
to give up, you know.
or a bumper sticker reminding me everyday,
that was really great!